it's like right
um Brees wedding day house Goldberg good
look at you little princess getting
ready big day for you
the first calls gonna change okay I'm
fine pretty bride robot nobody now hold
on oh all right I guess we should
probably start you ready now huh yeah
this is what we're doing our makeup wow
this is like - up close and personal
it's super close life but it's it is
good it's honest it's keeping us honest
we're baking we're making fake fake baby
great yeah where's your dress in here
ready are you ready for it are you ready
for it wow you can please me Bri it's
really pretty
Oh Maddie wants to see I think that's a
good idea how they did that where you
could close the blinds yeah they've
thought of everything I gotta finish
getting right now I not accomplished
anything guys I was so pretty so they're
sizes I mean
tell him why not
none unnatural no she
yesterday she did like this all natural
and I'm like it's not last
it's not fake enough like Francesca
falling from California's life in
California to do Brees makeup for
wedding and she did
oh this sweet eye I made a bar mean it
looks really pretty oh thank you this is
your fine where's my shoes I'm not their
own yeah they don't sing it I ever even
tried my shoes on yet you sign my did
you all see what oh wait you might kiss
my head don't you check about that
that's not what the variables are like
you're okay sweetie doing okay are you
doing it babe is that you say I do speak
speak little baby me it's my baby very
pretty here I wasn't very good guys I
just realized this is Bria's last
moments of being a single woman okay oh
my god
he's on the hold it there's a lot of
things going on yeah um no gluten enough
can we not do that we not you huh oh
okay
the ceremony's about to begin someone
leave you guys here and I'm gonna switch
to another camera where you go Bree I'm
gonna get married you look so pretty
gonna get remarried yeah this is nice
please go on to the chapel and she's
gonna get married I don't know the rest
of the sex what if I fell out thousand
kontrick I'll be filming there's anyone
falling out hold onto your dress please
goin to the chapel which into your town
I need you tonight together we can go
crazy we can put out the lights together
we can go we can go up straight in your
eyes and everything is so hey say it's
just you and I
and everything is so sorry
you can go crazy
okay I'm meeting digitial Bree is
officially married brie and Bryan who's
excited hey guys all okay being on
YouTube
yeah okay cool okay we have verbal
confirmations from everyone let's meet
them this is so so cute and so pretty
cool I'm freezing okay
yeah we're cold it's a it's it's a
pretty cold site mm-hmm everybody else
was like yeah we can do
oh that's great how are you feeling good
yeah never gonna give you up that was
your doing
I want to never gonna give you down
first dance is happening do we get up
first and you be good to my sister
leave it of all the songs to come on
they had to be friends
oh my god he's actually crazy
all right now that Ryan has the Garter
let's get our bouquet and all of the
subtle Oh actually have to be single get
out here
I was like no we all want to know why
I'm laughing so hard
I'm not catching anything no not me no
it's not me
Oh
what's your name
we gonna get quite a few we got a big
party going on oh how are you
there's a screen doors if you don't
agree wait for that video or person have
you every time trick hair doing you
straighten it today
well the humidity is is ruining it the
girl is Oh God we're gonna struggle
Wow
nextdoor don't give it to you
yeah stop
stop
Wow
maybe water from
you
the
thank you
ah
well Eddie's gonna grab the drone no
don't try to guess his own that's also
dangerous fine he hasn't been drinking
them ports please don't climb any higher